how did America rise up from a backwoods
country to be one of the greatest
nations the world has ever known
we pioneered industries and all of this
required the greatest innovations in
science and technology in the world and
so science is a fundamental part of the
country that we are but in this the 21st
century when it comes time to make
decisions about science it seems to me
people have lost the ability to judge
what is true and what is not what is
reliable what is not reliable
what should you believe what should you
not believe and when you have people who
don't know much about science standing
in denial of it and rising to power that
is a recipe for the complete dismantling
of our informed democracy let us demand
that educators around America teach
evolution not as fact but its theory
increasing number of parents showing
skepticism about vaccinations voters
have approved a ban on GMOs climate
change unproven science that's not the
country I remember growing up in not
that we didn't have challenges
I'm old enough to remember the 60s in
the 70s got a hot war in a cold war
civil rights movement and all this was
going on but I don't remember any time
where people were standing in denial of
what science was one of the great things
about science is that it is an entire
exercise in finding what is true the
hypothesis you tested I get a result a
rival of mine double checks it because
they think I might be wrong they perform
an even better experiment that I did and
they find out a this experiment matches
oh my gosh we're onto something here
and out of this rises a new emergent
truth it does it better than anything
else we have ever come up with and as
human beings
this is science it's not something to
toy with
it's not something to say I choose not
to believe equals mc-squared
you don't have that option when you have
an established scientific emergent truth
it is true whether or not you believe in
it and the sooner you understand that
the faster we can get on with the
political conversations about how to
solve the problems that face us so once
you understand that humans are warming
the planet you can then have a political
conversation about that you can say well
should we are there carbon credits do we
do this do we put a tariff on it do we
fund do we subsidize those those have
political answers and every minute one
is in denial you are delaying the
political solution that should have been
established years ago
as a voter as a citizen scientific
issues will come before you and isn't it
worth it to say all right let me at
least become scientifically literate so
that I can think about these issues and
act intelligently upon recognize what
science is and allow it to be what it
can and should be in the service of
civilization it's in our hands